rivard donc par les états unis avec la
riposte de donald trump dans l' enquête
parlementaire sur l'assaut du capitole
l'ancien président américain s'est
pourvue en justice pour bloquer la
divulgation de documents secrets oui
l'objectif est bien c'est d'éviter que
d'anciens collaborateurs fournisse des
preuves donald trump invoque le droit à
garder certaines informations secrètes
comme le prévoit la cour suprême les
explications de thomas bonnet depuis
washington
la plainte de l'ancien président des
états unis a été rendue publique en
début de semaine rendant officiel ce que
de nombreux médias américains relayait
déjà depuis plusieurs jours donald trump
a donc décidé de lancer une procédure
judiciaire pour bloquer la divulgation
de documents et de communications datant
de la période où il était encore à la
maison blanche c'est une réponse à la
requête de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire en charge des événements
du 6 janvier une commission dont donald
trump dit qu elle est partisane écouter
la requête de la commission n'est rien
d'autre qu'une tentative vexatoire et
illégal d'aller à la pêche aux
informations ouvertement soutenu par
baden est conçu pour enquêter
anticonstitutionnellement sur le
président trump et son administration
cette commission souhaite en effet
auditionné des proches de donald trump
ainsi qu'avoir accès à des documents
officiels et ce afin de pouvoir enquêter
sur le rôle et le niveau d'implication
de donald trump pour les violences qui
se sont déroulés le 6 janvier dernier au
capitole et parmi les témoins assignés
figurent notamment un style baden qui ne
s'est pas rendu à sa convocation
conformément à la marche à suivre qui
avait donné les avocats de donald trump
il invoque le privilège exécutif c'est
un dispositif juridique qui rend
confidentielles les documents et les
communications des présidents américains
un aspect légal qui fait débat puisque
si la jurisprudence de la cour suprême
attestent en effet de cette
confidentialité elle ne s'est jamais en
réalité prononcer sur son usage par un
ancien président américain alors pour
les parlementaires qui forment cette
commission denquête il s'agit tout
simplement d'une manoeuvre visant à
gagner du temps écouter l'objectif clair
de l'ancien président est d'empêcher la
commission d'avoir accès au fait
concernant le 6 janvier et sa plainte
n'est rien de plus qu'une tentative de
retarder et d'entravé notre enquête
c'est en fait la maison blanche qui a le
pouvoir de délivrer ou non un certain
nombre de documents à cette commission d
enquête parlementaire alors face à ce
qui est présenté par l'administration de
joe biden comme des circonstances
extraordinaires elle a décidé il ya
quelques jours d'autoriser les archives
nationales à fournir une première salve
de documents à cette commission denquête
une procédure d'exception qui pourrait
aussi s'appliquer au cas de steve banen
selon les informations rapportées dans
la presse américaine au delà du bras de
fer juridique donc il s'agit bel et bien
d'une opposition politique entre donald
trump et son successeur à la maison
blanche